a via a via nous connaissons tous l'histoire de la
belle au bois dormant donc nous savons que maléfique nous
savons ce qui s'est passé lors de ce baptême
mais nous n'avons jamais su ce qui s'est passé
avant c'est l'histoire classique de la
belle au bois dormant plus tellement plus d'
œuf de jus était-ce la nuit poivre  Jennifer Dodd
allo motivo dit à Akiva Vata que j'ai presque
pensé quand j'ai regardé un film d'animation
que je n'avais pas super peur de Maléfique
quand je le regarde j'ai toujours toujours été
intriguée par elle j'ai regardé le film
et j'ai trouvé des idées qui en
révélaient plus  à propos du personnage a
créé un passé pour elle qui a conduit au
moment où elle maudit Aurora puis
nous emmène au-delà de ce moment du
point de vue de la malveillance Je sais que c'est une
réinvention pas seulement un récit de la
même histoire que vous modifiez bhakti fait son
meurtre
lavage de lion  hors de ce film nous donne l'
occasion de découvrir l'histoire de
Maléfique et ce qui l'a conduite du
côté obscur,
nous avons respecté le classique, nous avons essayé
de vous apporter ce que vous aimez dans cette
histoire avec  Nous espérons aussi apporter un monde que
vous n'avez jamais vu auparavant
c'est une très belle histoire et je pense
que c'est très différent de ce à quoi les
gens vont s'attendre